>>> THAT'S WHY YOU DIDN'T GO TO
GRAD SCHOOL?
AMAZING.
>> YEAH.
YOU KNOW, I HAD A GREAT TIME
TONIGHT.
>> ME TOO.
WE'VE HAD THREE INCREDIBLE
DATES.
>> YEAH.
DEFINITELY.
HEY, UM, CAN I ASK SOMETHING?
>> ANYTHING.
>> WHY DO YOU ALWAYS WEAR THAT
GREEN RIBBON AROUND YOUR NECK?
>> UM, WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> I'VE JUST NEVER SEEN YOU
WITHOUT IT.
WHY DON'T YOU TAKE IT OFF?
>> I HOPED YOU WOULDN'T NOTICE.
LOOK, ALAN, I'LL SHOW YOU.
BUT PLEASE DON'T LET IT AFFECT
THE WAY YOU SEE ME.
>> OF COURSE NOT, COME ON.
>> ALL RIGHT, HERE WE GO.
[ CHANTING ]
♪♪
THERE.
NOW YOU KNOW.
THERE'S A LITTLE MEATBALL GUY ON
THE SIDE OF MY NECK.
EVERY I TAKE THE GREEN RIBBON
OFF AND EXPOSE HIM TO LIGHT, HE
WAKES UP AND SINGS HIS LITTLE
SONGS.
DOES THAT CLEAR THINGS UP FOR
YOU?
>> TOTALLY, 100%.
>> GOOD.
NOW WHERE WERE WE?
>> JUST ONE QUESTION.
IS THAT A LITTLE TINY HAND
STICKING OUT OF THE TOP OF YOUR
SHIRT?
>> I WAS HOPING YOU WOULDN'T
NOTICE.
♪♪
AND TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION,
YEAH, THEY HARMONIZE AND SING
TOGETHER IN TIME.
[ CHANTING IN SYNC ]
THEN THERE'S THESE GUYS.
AND THIS ONE KIND OF MUNCHES ON
A BLOCK OF CHEESE TO THE BEAT.
AND THIS ONE JUST KIND OF SPITS
UP.
THEN BIG DADDY BRINGS IT ALL
TOGETHER.
[ CHANTING AND SINGING IN
CHORUS ]
♪♪
♪ SINGING OUR LITTLE MEATBALL
SONG ♪
♪ WE ARE LITTLE MEATBALL MEN ♪
♪ JOIN US PLEASE AND SING
ALONG ♪
>> OKAY, I THINK I GET IT.
YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND COVER THEM
UP NOW.
>> OH, NO, NO, ONCE THEY GET ON
A ROLL LIKE THIS IT'S BETTER TO
KEEP THEM GOING UNTIL THEY GET
TUCKERED OUT.
♪♪
♪ WE ARE LITTLE MEATBALL MEN ♪
♪ WE ARE BALLS OF BODY MEAT ♪
♪ SUCKING ON OUR PIECE OF
♪ WE ARE LITTLE MEATBALL MEN ♪
CHEESE ♪
♪ SUCKING ON OUR PIECE OF
♪ MY NAME IS CHUNKY ♪
CHEESE ♪
♪ AND MY NAME'S POPOLIM ♪
♪ MY NAME IS CHUNKY ♪
♪ MY NAME IS JOBI ♪
♪ AND MY NAME'S POPOLIM ♪
♪ AND MY NAME IS JIM ♪
♪ MY NAME IS JOBI ♪
♪♪
♪ AND MY NAME IS JIM ♪
>> HAVE YOU EVER TALKED TO A
♪♪
DOCTOR ABOUT GETTING THEM
>> HAVE YOU EVER TALKED TO A
REMOVED?
DOCTOR ABOUT GETTING THEM
>> OH, IT'S NOT NECESSARY.
REMOVED?
AFTER A FEW YEARS THEY JUST,
>> OH, IT'S NOT NECESSARY.
LIKE, DRY AND UP FALL OFF INTO A
AFTER A FEW YEARS THEY JUST,
TOILET.
LIKE, DRY AND UP FALL OFF INTO A
>> HEY BUDDY I'M HUNGRY.
TOILET.
GIVE ME SOME MORE CHEESE.
>> HEY BUDDY I'M HUNGRY.
>> OH, GROSS.
GIVE ME SOME MORE CHEESE.
>> OH, DON'T WORRY ABOUT THAT,
>> OH, GROSS.
IT'S NOT POISONOUS OR ANYTHING.
>> OH, DON'T WORRY ABOUT THAT,
IT'LL JUST STAIN YOUR CLOTHES.
IT'S NOT POISONOUS OR ANYTHING.
AND IT IS POISONOUS.
IT'LL JUST STAIN YOUR CLOTHES.
>> OKAY, LOOK.
AND IT IS POISONOUS.
I THINK WE'RE MOVING TOO FAST.
>> OKAY, LOOK.
>> OH, NO, HERE IT COMES!
I THINK WE'RE MOVING TOO FAST.
>> OH, THIS IS SO AWKWARD, I
>> OH, NO, HERE IT COMES!
CAN'T BEAR TO WATCH.
>> OH, THIS IS SO AWKWARD, I
>> ARE YOU SERIOUS?
CAN'T BEAR TO WATCH.
YOU'RE DUMPING ME?
>> ARE YOU SERIOUS?
THIS IS COMING OUT OF NOWHERE!
YOU'RE DUMPING ME?
I MEAN, I SUPPOSE IF I HAD TO
THIS IS COMING OUT OF NOWHERE!
GUESS I'D SAY IT HAD MAYBE
I MEAN, I SUPPOSE IF I HAD TO
SOMETHING TO DO WITH THE
GUESS I'D SAY IT HAD MAYBE
MEATBALLS?
SOMETHING TO DO WITH THE
>> NO.
MEATBALLS?
NO.
>> NO.
YEAH, IT'S THE MEATBALLS.
NO.
>> WOW.
YEAH, IT'S THE MEATBALLS.
WOW.
>> WOW.
[ CRYING ]
WOW.
>> HEY.
[ CRYING ]
♪♪
>> HEY.
I'M SORRY.
♪♪
IS THAT A PIANO IN YOUR ARMPIT?
I'M SORRY.
>> UH-HUH.
IS THAT A PIANO IN YOUR ARMPIT?
♪ DON'T GIVE UP ON LOVE ♪
>> UH-HUH.
♪ JUST BECAUSE OF SOME
♪ DON'T GIVE UP ON LOVE ♪
MEATBALLS ♪
♪ JUST BECAUSE OF SOME
♪ DON'T GIVE UP ON THIS GIRL
MEATBALLS ♪
BECAUSE SHE'S GOT
♪ DON'T GIVE UP ON THIS GIRL
A LOT OF MEATBALLS ♪
BECAUSE SHE'S GOT
♪ SOMEDAY YOU'LL REALIZE
A LOT OF MEATBALLS ♪
THAT IN THE END ♪
♪ SOMEDAY YOU'LL REALIZE
♪ YOUR LOVE WILL ALWAYS WIN ♪
THAT IN THE END ♪
♪ AND I'M JIM ♪
♪ YOUR LOVE WILL ALWAYS WIN ♪
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
♪ AND I'M JIM ♪
THE MEATBALLS ARE RIGHT.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M GOING TO MAKE IT WORK.
THE MEATBALLS ARE RIGHT.
>> REALLY?
I'M GOING TO MAKE IT WORK.
>> WE FINALLY GOT A BOYFRIEND,
>> REALLY?
YAY!
>> WE FINALLY GOT A BOYFRIEND,
>> YAY!
YAY!
>> WHAT THE HELL?
>> YAY!
>> OH, YEAH, I FORGOT TO
>> WHAT THE HELL?
MENTION, THEY'RE EXTREMELY
>> OH, YEAH, I FORGOT TO
CONTAGIOUS.
MENTION, THEY'RE EXTREMELY
>> NOOOO!